[Música]
i
ah
nuestro tiempo en la vida es limitado
tiene miles de 17 minutos 56 segundos mi
nombre es julio de laiglesia soy te dás
técnico especialista en desactivación de
artefactos explosivos y os confieso que
tengo miedo porque este es mi mundo una
bomba y una cuenta atrás donde
desactivarla y en medio muchos miedos
que gestionar y muy poco margen para los
errores pero mi experiencia me ha
demostrado que cuando afrontamos el
miedo lo normal es que lo superemos y
para ello he creado una fórmula basada
en mi experiencia y en la de otros que
como yo literalmente se juegan la vida y
que en situaciones de alto riesgo nos ha
ayudado a nosotros ya nuestros equipos a
superarlo porque tener miedo es
inevitable pero superarlo es una
decisión
empecemos por definir qué es el miedo es
una emoción provocada por la percepción
de un peligro real o imaginario presente
o futuro esto es algo que nos diferencia
del resto de las especies tenemos cosas
o situaciones que no han ocurrido nunca
y que quizás nunca se produzcan
y yo os pregunto a qué tenéis miedo
pensarlo
y si superar nuestro miedo personal o
profesional fuese una cuestión de vida o
muerte
queréis que os ayudaría a tomar
decisiones más valientes más audaces más
comprometidas si vuestra vida estuviese
en juego delegar y es la responsabilidad
le pasaría es la pelota a otro or
distrae 10 de vuestro objetivo verdad
que no
y que es lo primero que necesitamos para
vencer nuestro miedo una motivación un
para que yo viniendo hacia aquí
recordaba lo que a mí me había motivado
a ser un te das porque yo de pequeño lo
que quería hacer era un madelman
uno de estos muñecos pequeños
articulados de 17 centímetros con ellos
yo podría imaginar y vivir todo tipo de
aventuras y de afrontar los mayores
peligros sin miedo porque como su lema
decía podían con todo eso es lo que yo
quería ser lo descubrí un día con ocho
años cuando decidí escaparme de casa
soy el mayor de cuatro hermanos y el
peor estudiante con diferencia yo lo
suspendía todo hasta el recreo era lo
que ahora llaman un fracaso escolar y en
mi tiempo te llamaban tonto a secas así
que un día decidí que para que volver al
colegio arranqué una hoja del cuaderno y
escribir papá mamá me voy a dar la
vuelta al mundo
no os preocupéis estaré bien y volveré
pronto os quiero
julito
y ya lo creo que volví pronto al caer la
noche estaba solo muerto de frío se me
habían acabar las provisiones así que
decidí volver cuando llegue mi padre
tenía entre sus manos la nota que yo
había escrito y me preguntó qué
significa esto hijo
yo no podía pensar ni - a hablar pero me
salió la verdad
para para que no quiero estudiar mi
padre sin levantar la voz me miró
fijamente y me dijo
hijo tienes que ser responsable tienes
que cumplir con tu deber sólo hay un
camino trabajo trabajo y trabajo pero
como te cuesta tanto trabajo estudiar
pide no es lo que quieras que entre tu
madre y yo lucharemos por conseguirlo y
yo le dije quiero quiero un madelman un
made man busco este madre man
pero a cambio tienes que aprobar el
curso hecho y lo probé y me recuerdo
toda una tarde metido en esa bañera con
este muñeco una y otra vez sumergiendo
lo ahí en un baño de espuma cuál fue el
secreto encontrar una motivación
superior a mi esfuerzo que era estudiar
y es que estar donde no quieres te
empuja hacia dónde quieres el miedo a
fracasar puede ser un gran motivador
yo he utilizado como una palanca
deje de ser un fracaso escolar cuando
encontré mi misión ayudar a los demás
ser un policía y entonces apareció para
mí un miedo terrible
el miedo a suspender a no conseguirlo y
pensé que es lo contrario del miedo la
seguridad y cómo puedo ganar más
seguridad pues estudiando y entrenando
el doble y así lo hice finalmente acabé
el número uno de la promoción pasaron
los años y me presenté a oficial volví a
sacar el número uno luego a su inspector
el número dos y finalmente fui el número
uno de los te das profesión que ejerce
actualmente y que os quiero decir con
esto que cuando conectamos con nuestra
identidad con nuestra misión es cuando
se despliega todo nuestro potencial
y nuestros héroes pueden porque creen
que pueden porque su autoconfianza es
colosal y es que nada en nuestra manera
de pensar de sentir de decidir o de
actuar es ajeno a esa influencia de
nuestra autoestima todos somos únicos
completos y capaces de conseguir lo que
nos propongamos
aunque una creencia errónea de que las
grandes hazañas de que las acciones
heroicas es sólo de hombres y mujeres
excepcionales como nadal y yo
dotados de unos recursos físicos
intelectuales y psicológicos fuera de lo
común y no es así todos llevamos a un
héroe a un valiente que está dispuesto a
salir si creemos en él
lo que de verdad les diferencia es algo
muy humano es una motivación superior a
su miedo al esfuerzo de vencerlo y una
actitud de combate que les impide
rendirse ante la adversidad sea cual sea
y estaremos de acuerdo en que eso marca
una gran diferencia en la vida privada y
en las relaciones y en las
organizaciones y yo os pregunto se puede
aprender a ser valiente
aristóteles decía que no se puede llamar
valiente aquel que no siente miedo el
temerario el que no percibe el peligro
decía es un loco o un insensato solo es
valiente aquel que actúa a pesar del
miedo por lo tanto el miedo es de
valientes responde un ejemplo por favor
levantar la mano
los que paseando por un pueblo de
montaña había 6 acá era una persona
desde un puente a un río de agua bravas
y 16 lo voy a salvar cuantos os
arriesgaría
bueno hay algún valiente muy bien y si
fuese un niño el que se estuviese
ahogando cuantos os tiráis
algunos más
y si fuese tu hijo o tu hija
bueno todavía algunos se lo piensan
con la vida que me da que me lo cuide el
señor
como veis el truco para ser valiente
consiste en someter nuestro miedo a un
juicio de inteligencia y buscar una
motivación un valor fundamental para
nosotros que esté en peligro y que nos
impulse a actuar con coraje y
determinación
así un carácter miedoso puede dar a luz
un acto valeroso y es que todos podemos
ser valientes si encontramos una fuerte
motivación que sea más importante que
nuestro miedo
decía madame curie que dejamos de temer
aquello que empezamos a conocer
en el análisis y en el control de
situaciones de alto riesgo lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es atender a tres
parámetros a nuestro cuerpo a nuestra
mente ya nuestra atención
si yo adopto una corporalidad de
victoria es muy difícil que yo me dé por
vencido porque mi cuerpo le dice a mi
mente cómo actuar le dice estamos
preparados para el desafío
en segundo lugar colocó a un centinela
en mi cerebro que deje pasar los
pensamientos enfocados en la tarea en la
solución y bloqueé otros que vengan con
el lema no puedo no valgo
si queremos controlar la situación
tenemos que controlar nuestros
pensamientos
tenemos que sacar esa actitud de combate
y por último atención plena en el
instante presente donde pones tu
atención es tu elección donde la quieres
poner en el problema buena solución
tenemos que mantener a raya la
imaginación este es el cable rojo en la
desactivación del miedo la angustia y el
estrés están estrechamente relacionados
con imaginar un mal futuro y si fracaso
y si suspendo y si me despiden y si es
un tumor
tenemos que estar en el momento presente
con conciencia de que estamos ante un
reto con la aceptación de que es normal
que sintamos miedo pero con una actitud
de combate que nos haga ver que nuestro
futuro está estrechamente relacionado
con lo que hagamos o dejemos de hacer
aquí y no de la suerte o el destino
por el contrario esas personas que se
instalan en el papel de víctimas
esperando resignado a su suerte
generalmente se convierten en parte del
problema todos conocemos a alguna
persona en nuestra empresa que es parte
del problema verdad
esto no se estudia en las escuelas de
negocio esto se aprende cuando te das
cuenta de que quejarte lamentarte
echarle la culpa al otro al sistema al
mercado a la crisis no te salva
te darán la razón te consolarán pero no
tendrás éxito
aquello que te habías propuesto no lo
habrás conseguido y si algo me ha
enseñado a mi trabajo es que lo que de
verdad importa es que lo consigas que
vuelvas a casa vivo y con el deber
cumplido
cuando analizamos esta situación de
riesgo de peligro yo lo que hago es
cambiar la palabra miedo por falta de
conocimiento y empiezo a recabar ya
contrastar toda la información para
analizar la realidad tal y como es no
como era ni cómo me gustaría que fuese
porque cuando tenemos miedo lo que más
tenemos son preguntas sin resolver que
tenemos que contestar con información
veraz y con datos fiables que nos
aporten conocimiento porque el
conocimiento delimita los riesgos y abre
estrategias de acción y la posibilidad
de tomar buenas decisiones
pero a veces la situación se ha puesto
tan fea que solo podemos elegir entre la
mala y la peor
en estos casos lo primero es apagar el
fuego cortar la hemorragia y luego
hacernos dos preguntas que quiero
conseguir
y que necesito saber y hacer para
conseguirlo para no fallar
porque confiar en la buena suerte es una
temeridad es un salto en la oscuridad en
la empresa en la vida queremos seguridad
certidumbre no queremos cometer errores
pero cuántos de nosotros hemos tomado
decisiones importantes en nuestra vida
sin totales garantías de éxito sabiendo
que la seguridad total no existe que el
riesgo cero no existe
que lo que de verdad importa es revisar
dos niveles antes de pasar a la acción
el primero es el nivel de compromiso que
tenemos con alcanzar nuestro objetivo
tiene que ser del 100% como el agua al
hervir a 99 grados no hierve ese grado
puede ser la diferencia entre ganar o
perder entre vivir o morir
la gente elige vivir es curioso
pero la mayoría de nosotros nos damos
una tercera opción sobre vivir más vivir
querer a medias nadar y guardar la ropa
esforzarnos pero sólo un poco luchar
pero sin jugarnos la vida y a veces para
salvar la vida tu relación con tu
negocio te la tienes que jugar tienes
que darlo todo
muchas personas y equipos se rinden
justo antes de ganar y es porque su
compromiso no era del 100%
el segundo es el nivel de competencia
para llevar la causa decisión que hemos
tomado claro que la motivación es
importante y que la actitud como dice
víctor cooper multiplica pero si yo no
tengo la formación si yo no soy
competente en mi trabajo se ve la
próxima baja motivación sin competencia
lleva al error
permitirme la expresión es que me
convierto en un tonto útil un tonto
motivado
soy más peligroso que una caja de bombas
no hay que tener miedo a cometer errores
hay que tener miedo a no aprender de
ellos lo que es un fracaso es persistir
en el error esperando que esta vez sea
la solución
persistir en el error es un error yo
como te das no puedo fallar el fracaso
en mi trabajo siempre ha sido una
tragedia mi compromiso con el éxito es
del cien por cien para mí la mejor
garantía de éxito es la formación el
entrenamiento y la constancia
no está el foco en que no cometamos
errores el punto de mira está en
ambición al hacer las cosas bien en dar
lo mejor de nosotros en lo mínimo que
hagamos ese es el camino para obtener un
trabajo realmente excepcional y
trascendente reducir los errores o
alcanzar el éxito será una consecuencia
lógica de esa excelencia
y lo más importante solo en la acción
nos enfrentamos y superamos a nuestro
miedo yo os pregunto cuántos de vosotros
habéis aprendido a montar en bici viendo
el tour de francia' sentados en el sofá
de vuestra casa
ninguno no porque la razón nos dice lo
que debemos hacer pero no nos da la
orden de hacerlo se mueve en el mundo de
las ideas no de la acción va a ser el
coraje el que nos permita dar ese salto
de la razón a la acción acabando con
nuestras indecisión es el coraje es
mayor cuando no hay vuelta atrás cuando
rendirte no te salva voltear o escribió
que el coraje no es una virtud sino una
cualidad de los grandes hombres y
mujeres todos los hombres y mujeres
estamos asustados la primera vez que
entramos en acción pero yo os aseguro
que si actuáis como valientes acabaréis
siendo valientes
porque lo que entrenamos es lo que luego
haremos bajo presión es de la práctica y
el entrenamiento lo que hace al
especialista y al maestro
esa firmeza de ánimo esa confianza en
nosotros mismos es lo esencial cuanto
más complicadas en una situación más
serenidad de presencia
y como último recurso para pasar a la
acción tenemos el cumplimiento del deber
es el deber del que me hablaba a mi
padre cuando yo era un niño
hace 23 años aproximadamente yo estaba a
punto de entrar a los tedax pero
pertenecía a un grupo antiterrorista
y una mañana nos llamaron para decirnos
que un paquete-bomba la vía bola una
mano a un cartero en cibeles cuando
llegamos allí los zetas nos dijeron que
había otra que nos escondiéramos que nos
atrincheramos que la iban a desactivar
desde el parapeto donde yo estaba no
podía dejar de mirar esos 50 metros que
ese hombre recorrió con ese traje hasta
la bomba a mí se me hicieron eternos
cuando lo desactivó y volvió le pregunté
pero como has podido desactivar esa
bomba
y me dijo es mi deber este deber es el
que organiza el comportamiento libre es
una conducta aprendida que nos impulsa a
hacer lo que debemos aunque esté en
conflicto con nuestros derechos yo este
fin de semana tengo derecho a descansar
a navegar a cenar pero si me
comprometido con un proyecto y tengo que
trabajar lo haré me lo dice mi deber
este deber yo lo adquirí cuando me
comprometí contigo no tengo nada que
pensar
se trata de perseverar en lo que debemos
hacer sin pensar en lo que tenemos que
sufrir
me gustaría terminar reflexionando con
todos vosotros sobre cómo queremos vivir
si como cobardes o como valientes hoy
más que nunca el mundo necesita de
héroes y heroínas como vosotros de carne
y hueso debemos de dejar de ser
invisibles para convertirnos en líderes
inspiradores de hombres y mujeres justos
leales y valientes todos estamos
llamados a serlo pero pocos los
convencidos de conseguirlo yo os invito
a crecer ya desplegar ese potencial de
ese héroe de ese valiente que lleváis
dentro para crecer realmente como
personas y como profesionales y para
llevar una vida con sentido
recordad que si no hacemos esfuerzos que
si no nos arriesgamos probablemente
nuestra vida y nuestro trabajo no será
lo que esperábamos lo que habíamos
diseñado lo que habíamos soñado
yo al final lo conseguí me convertí en
aquello que había soñado en un madelman
en el mante das y conseguirlo ha sido
una aventura fantástica como la de mi
juguete favorito
no lo olviden el miedo es de valientes
no se den nunca más por vencidos
y nos ha sobrado 36 segundos nos hemos
salvado muchas gracias
i
ah